hello everybody my name is bono priori
Darin I am a postdoc at the Scripps
Research Institute in Florida and today
I am going to talk about addressing the
scalability of human iPS it derived
neurons for HTS or high-throughput
screening implementation using
phenotypic screening approach
brief overview of the presentation
initially I'll talk a few minutes about
the script Research Institute the
Student Center over here and one of the
background and the motivation behind
this project and how we went about
establishing an essay for this
phenotypic screen and also completely
talk about our bizzy's models using the
induced neurons for the syngas disease
and also quickly summarize and tell you
a few things about where we are headed
next with this project
so briefly the screaming center here at
Scripps started in 2005 and it's a
interdisciplinary team made up of
biologists chemists and engineers and we
have industrial scale robotics which is
what makes us very unique being an
academic lab in an industrial onset of
equipments and liquid platform
dispensers and everything including a
huge rug library and the funding is
driven by both NIH federal grants and
from the pharma and biotech
and there are three you could divide the
lab into three parts the first part is
over what I work or the fun part as I
like to call it where most of the asset
development where we get a saison
96-well plates or 24 well plate and we
optimize it to 384 or 1536 and then the
second part is a robotic part where it
goes into the robot and our robotic
engineers overlook this the screaming
part with 1536 and we go up to hundred
thousand samples per day and everything
is automated at this point in the last
part of the compound management that
comes more into play once the assay is
passed the primary and secondary screen
and the tools used for this exploration
pretty much majorly comes from thermo
Fisher starts off with diviner power
using the fill inside leads the bsl-2
facility UV console emitter
PerkinElmer and envision pinto station
and thermal only
why do we care about induced neurons
right so there's a huge lack of
preclinical models sorry and the golden
standard today for neuro drug testing
it's pretty much just models primary
neurons but they don't obviously
translate the human neurons because of
the increased complexity and also in
talking about human neurons right now
they are being made from IPS es but they
have not been made in amounts that are
scalable for industrial scale screening
so they're very slow to make human
neurons and it's very variable from
batch to batch from patient to patient
now how do I make this human neurons
rate so the rationale behind in these
neurons from IPS see being this is
virtually unlimited supply of IPS these
from patients there is no ethical
complications because these are adult
cells and you can also make PDX models
and test both the 2d and upcoming
experiments using 3d and also bank it
and go back to any further testing you
want to do with these IPS C based
neurons using human neurons phenotypic
asset development is also another area
that's gaining a lot of momentum and we
want to develop assays that are
statistically significant using good
good plate statistics like C primes and
signal basal and in desh have the best
ass in the shortest time possible
so the current techniques to make
induced neurons are let me place a focus
our condition on the left side of the
slide as you can see it's numbered so it
goes from fibroblast to neurons and or
going from fibroblast to IPS sees from
ipsa is the neural progenitor cells and
from your paternity results or npcs to
induce neurons now obviously these are
all long and complicated a multi-step
approaches to what we want to do was to
get an IPS in cell line with ability to
now let the fact cost effective
homogeneous method to make in these
neurons and develop a human phenotypic
assays that are high throughput
screening friendly how do we go about
doing that the first step is to get a IP
SEC airline that was validated from
thermal this was received as a gift from
thermal and we were able to bank because
it's a cell line we were able to Bank
about a hundred trials with early
passages and be routinely q seated for
mycoplasma and pluripotency from time to
time and also we have an rfid encoded
freezer pro to have a good record on how
many vials of each passage was remaining
now these are all very important when
you talk about large-scale robotics and
screening and how to maintain these
systems in puri potency was a two step
confirmation in our case so the image on
the left was the first immunity idol
staining of the Casman IPSC and all i
don't have to preach to the choir but
you all know sse and opt for our surface
markers for fluid put in stem cells and
then these cells check checked out
positive for these both markers and then
we moved on to a more comprehensive and
detailed taxmen scorecard once again
that was from thermal so what that's
what this scorecard does if there is a
PCR based method where we put in the RNA
or the cDNA and use out it's already has
primers in a pre plated format
and once it kind of queries it against
the database it gives you a score card
that has all the information that come
what are the sulfur Newell genes and the
problem of an algorithm score and does
it solve the macular mesoderm or the
other three germ layers basically so as
you can see with the right arrow pointed
it falls under the self renewal box but
confirming that these cell lines are in
the pluripotent and they do not fall
under any of those germ layer which is a
good this is what we needed to confirm
so once these two QCs were in place from
time to time for every passage kind of
moved on to actually start making the
neurons these neurons were made from by
plating the IPS ES and I won't go into
too much detail but briefly we used
lentiviral transduction and DOX
activation and pure myosin selection to
make IPS induced neurons for my PSE now
once they were selected using pure mice
in these in these models were created or
enzyme just going to call them ends they
were plated on 384-well plate for now
when we were able to pin them with
compounds and then analyze them 48 hours
later our goal in this case was to just
reduce the timeline because most of the
neural gyro based assays were at least
14 days and up so we wanted to kind of
shorten the timeline and say we could do
this neuro screening within nine or ten
days right from creating the IPS e to
the final Rado
so the search is a check mark we're able
to get a lot of cells on demand now next
step to make these lentiviral the
dividers for us to get a lot of vectors
we got a bacterial start from a gene all
the sequences are public here is the ad
gene ID number we were able to make
transform using its dbl three cells and
once again i won't go into a lot of
detail on how we got these plasmids but
it's pretty straightforward and the only
thing we have to do because it's the HTS
lab what's the use maxie prep and create
a lot of virus a lot of sorry plasmids
and as you can see we come from the
right sequence of these plasmids using
restriction enzymes and and one and all
those clips is also on the right side of
the image now that the sequences are
verified and we have the right plasmid
in place we once again went to the next
step which is to make the virus and hi
traded for this process once again be
used for most viral power system and
using 293 FPS the plasmids were
expressed and they were extracted and
titrated so now on the image on the
right
II see a paneled GFP using GFP indicator
we were able to get good expression at
mo f1 which is great now we have a
method to make bulk a multi viral vector
so that you can make neurons on demand
the next so neurons are very sensitive
cells and they need a glial layer for
support when they grow especially for a
long time points then we have to explore
everything using their high throughput
in mind right scalability in mind now
how do we use human versus animal
astrocytes or could we explore other
surfaces so let's go to the first option
which is to use clear we did first think
about using human astrocytes because
these are human neurons but what
happened was that these astrocytes
require geoducks coated surfaces for
growth and we realize that these human
astrocytes do not
prolly free once again this is not a
scalable or an affordable proposition
moved on quickly to Sprague Dawley right
astrocytes and the problem here was we
were able to get a lot of astrocytes but
it took about four passages for clean up
because the primary neurons have a lot
of other type of cell microglia
contamination so I had to use IRC to
clean out the cultures and get a pure
population of astrocytes so it's not
only time consuming but it's also
reagent Hemme
alright so what do we do next
alternative solutions explore something
called the surface coating as most of
video scientists already know poly
d-lighting is a wonderful substrate that
helps helps these neurons to grow and
our lab has already published a paper
where we used to Pauly D lysine coated
384 well plates for a full primary
screen for most primary neurons but but
I was able to validate them on human
primary neurons as you can see the top
right panel
these were neurons image that day 23 on
a 384-well plate that had quality
license so these are already pre coded
we just get them as well plates which
make scalability easier now the second
approach instead of the lysine is orang
teen so we followed Kristin burn ants
left protocol to manually coat Polly D
lysine and laminin on a clear 384-well
plate and once again as you can see just
within day seven there was a lot of
proliferation and a lot of neural branch
points in these neurons so the question
is no longer glia right so now that
we're able to get good healthy neurons
flowing it's now changed to what is the
best surface coating which is a scalable
question to be able to answer
so once we got all that figured out and
optimized the last step was to actually
figure out what kind of endpoint or
analysis would make a lot of sense for
these induced neurons and using
appropriate controls you want to track
positive and negative control we DMSO or
result in a or wrote known and also look
at me write out growth as a as a
starting point using crc of the control
compound the two-channel assay which
i'll talk about very soon
you're right I'll birthday once again we
use thermal fissures high-content
reader to look at these new right
outgrowth and the reason we went for the
new right outgrowth is because it's a
well-established endpoint for
neurotoxicity a lot of labs use them and
it's early discovery and you could
always multiplex any right outgrowth
with other readouts like minor talk
on the output parameter which we were
most interested in seeing if the cell
body or the new read count new right
size and new right link we also were
interested in looking at branch point
count and to see cross point count as
well
now the nucleus count since I said it a
to channel a say right the data channel
or the nucleus channel was able to
provide that information and the other
neuron based parameters such as new
right cell body and branch point comes
in from the second channel the fitzy or
the rhodamine really depends on what day
you're using in this case as you can
seen the panel below all central
analysis if there is a neuron and this
is an image directly from the manual
from thermals high content reader and
that's how the segmentation and nuclear
cell body branch points are all coded
and I have a little image here that
shows little green blue and yellow
colors on the same image that shows how
these images are actually being
segmented and counted
now the next goal so to speak is to
adapt this into a 384-well plate and to
actually produce high volumes of ends
tested on various treatments ascertains
rapid readout and also can evaluate
plate to plate day to day and wall to
wall robustness for high-throughput
screening
you
here it says Shermer 384-well plate flow
chart how this is done
the 384-well plate starts off with 2500
cells in a 30 micron or culture medium
this is per well and after an overnight
incubation the compounds are added via
Pindell and in this gives you using 100
nanometre Pinto and after 48 hours of
incubation with the drug these cells are
then fixed
they are stained using once again
Thermal stearate outgrowth kit but any
other knee right over the kit should
work as well and then they are also read
in three channels using the high content
reader now the DNA analysis assets uses
only two channels and the output as I
already mentioned before or the ballade
neuron count then you write length per
wall and you read count per mole for now
the final volume of the assay study my
critter
and the final drug screening
concentration is 8.3 micro molar and
currently we were able to do low pack
screen on these neurons but this is the
you write outgrowth layout so to speak
so please focus your attention on the
first out of the top panel so if you
look at a priori for well played right
it has 24 columns and 16 rows first 2
columns column 1 and column 2 that saves
no souls because we wanted a column of
blank for any background subtraction
because it's served high content I say
that's a standard that's being followed
the second column is a DMSO trigger or
the positive control that does not
affect me right out Road at all and
there on the last 23 and 24 24 is the
pre fault in a that is a negative
control in this case or a column that
causes your IDE the new right leg to
shrink so that's a negative control the
use so the inhibition is high for these
compounds so it's an inhibition assay
and as you can see in the chart below
the percentage response refers to
percentage inhibition so
it's a compound that kills the neurons
or consignee right you would see a high
rate of inhibition which is what you see
in the breast cells and column these
dotted points refer to Brussels in a
pre-taped cells whereas the columns in
the bottom which is close to 0 which
means that neurons are fine and healthy
are all they all represent the base
length of the zero the reason we have
this dotted format is to look at if
there are any difference issues or is
there any plating issues or anything
like that such a format and and if you
look at the small tab that takes place
steps you look at the percentage CV and
a signal to the noise should be about 10
fold in this case and the C Prime's are
the ones we most care about and here you
go I have written down a Z prime of 0.5
in this case is considered good for
further analysis and that's substandard
that's commonly being followed for
passing high content cleaning
applications now what that actually
translates into images is what this
slide shows here the left top panel
shows an example of how a DMSO plate
looks and if you see you can see a lot
of new rights happily growing everywhere
and if you see before than a a 10
micromolar plan pinning concentration
you would see that it's almost very
little nuclei and new rights remaining
and that the panel right below it shows
how the software is able to isolate
these and give us a readout in terms of
once again if you look at the panel on
the right look at how does that
translate to a neuronal count how that
translates into a branch point you write
count and most importantly you're at
length so I guess the conclusion of this
slide is that we will be able to use
this near an outgrowth assay as an
endpoint especially to validate any any
compounds that cause New York City
beyond going just for you know high
throughput applications we wanted to
also see these neurons are actually
neuron like there will be collaborate
with Gavin rumba who is an investigator
or a neurobiologist at Scripps and his
lab we were able to collaborate and and
construct out that by map to and
synaptic icing staining we were able to
check that at day 30 these neurons
definitely stained for all mature
markers for developmental neurons like
dendrites and synapses and we also have
data which is not here but we have a 30
day electrophysiology data that shows
these neurons firing firing signals at
30 and 60 day time point
now that we were able to establish that
the neurons are scalable and they are
indeed mature neurons and they are
screen able in a phenotypic fashion I
just wanted to show you what that means
in terms of cost right so going from a
flask of cast iron high PSE they go to
neurons and by pure amazing selection
going to induce neurons and of course in
this case I only used hiked and hiked on
10th grade oh but there are other
readouts like mater talks or envision
motors and spaced quantitative readouts
but if you want to do something like
that
one plate would off IPSC alone would
cost about about $20 or for a low back
screen and triplicate it would cost
about $300 but if you wanted to induce
neurons it's about it's about two
thousand dollars which is not bad it is
very scalable compared to using my
primary neurons now you have a chance to
actually use human induced neurons and
moving a little bit ahead beyond just
this project we have been fortunate to
collaborate with Gavin rhombic lab who
works exclusively on thin gap disease
models now thin gap is a intellectual
disability that causes autism and
epileptic and cephalopod II and the
thing of one gene is haploid
insufficient so currently we were able
to generate using CRISPR and once again
this is a caste 9ip se cell line so it
was easy for us to create a caste nine
syngas
IPS see you were able to use that
catchment part of it and using CRISPR
max mixin gas IPS see and once you have
a singe fipse there's no you know to the
same method that I'd just described
using all the lentivirus and make some
gaps in this neuron out of these IPS
sees now our next step is to is we
already created syngas
neurons but we're now going to compare
homozygous and heterozygous knockouts of
these Leu so that now we can use it as a
control when we screen patient IPS is
our patient inducing
some of my cell lines are now being
validated by NGS
and this is really beyond just mural
right so the future directions I need
from our lab is to first of all harden
the existing system there is so many
options with respect to coating and
plastic ware and to kind of get the best
what is out there you have to spend a
lot more time validating on different
equipments validating on different plate
types and vendors available and also to
optimize the virus titer in-house and
work on look at looking at different
seeing densities depending on the length
of the assay and depending on their
endpoint that kind of leads to my second
point is to broaden beyond just the high
content that we just used for new right
outgrowth also go to other mitochondrial
health
another type of endpoints for neurons
and the third which we already underway
look at you know sim gap like we just
said but also can I'm talk about brain
on a dish because our lab has expertise
on 3d organoid model so we want to
exploit that expertise and work with
feeding in these neuron models to look
at early developmental disorders and
also just go beyond just neurons like
for example ocular degeneration and have
Patos earlier diseases maybe because we
have other needs for because we have an
IPS ISA line that can virtually be made
into any initial line that we want these
are very broad what we want to do for
the next kind of approaches none of
these work would have been possible
without this fantastic team so I would
like to thank Louis and Tim who are
their lead ID or these screening center
directors and for after development I
want to thank Chiron Vernie and Deanna
for helping me with high content and for
navigating this lab as such
okarin pair have been real help as long
as far as robotics is concerned and also
we want Hank Gavin Chris Murat and Maria
all from Gavin's lab who have helped us
with you know Titus training and for 30
day electrophysiology data and other
neurobiology and point
if you also want to thank thermo Fisher
especially David mark Erik and Steven
for helping ourselves helping with
expertise or any questions we have and
also for providing some reagents and
also checking back and helping us
whenever we we had some questions about
how to use these cell lines in these
reagents and also we want to thank NIH
for providing us the funding to be able
to continue doing this great project
thank you so much for your attention I
have my contact info on the first slide
so if you have any questions feel free
to email me thank you